Harvey Weinstein prepares for president
Morgan Freeman is accused of sexual
misconduct Joe Biden re-emerges to
challenge President Trump and we checked
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
so it's a real bad day in Hollywood
apparently if you are a famous actor
there is a good chance that you may go
to prison or be run out of the business
we'll talk about all that in just one
second first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at blue apron so blue
apron is the leading meal delivery kit
in the United States and many people
know what they do but if you haven't
heard what they do is they send you to
your house the best ingredients pre
packaged along with recipes and then you
cook the meals at yourself and it is so
good everyone around the office is a big
fan of blue apron for a reason they
offer a bunch of different plans they
offer meal plans and for convenience and
variety and flexibility they have our
twelve new recipes each week customers
can pick two three or four recipes based
on what best fits their schedule all of
their ingredients are high-quality they
only send non GMO ingredients meat with
no added hormones everybody around the
office is using blue apron it's become
extraordinarily popular across the
United States because I mean just listen
to the kinds of dishes that you could be
making in your own home with your kids
with your family by yourself you're
saving time you're saving money yeah I
mean it just takes a lot of time to get
the kids in the car and go to a
restaurant I mean instead you stay home
you cook with them it's a lot more fun
my four year old who loves cooking with
me now I'm sure that your family will do
the same with blue apron and listen to
some of this stuff salmon and spicy
orange sauce or with quinoa and carrot
salad white cheddar cheese burgers can't
I can't even sound great for you with
balsamic glazed onion and roasted
potatoes creamy pesto cavatelli with
mushrooms and spicy breadcrumbs I mean
these a restaurant-quality dishes you
will be making yourself in your home
I've heard from everybody that they are
just fantastic and when you go to blue
apron calm right now slash Shapiro you
get your first three meals before free
so check out this week's menu I got
those first three meals for free a blue
apron calm slash Shapiro again blue
apron calm slash apparel use that slash
appear oh say no that we say no get
those first three meals for free all
right so we begin today with the big
news being Harvey Weinstein has now
turned himself in he has been arrested
now what is he being arrested on
according to Joseph curl over at Daily
wire former Hollywood movie mogul Harvey
Weinstein on Friday turned himself into
police in New York what he likely will
face serious charge and connection
charges in connection to sexual assault
of at least two women more than 100
reporters cameramen and photographers
were on hand as when she made the perp
walk at the New York Police Department's
first Precinct in lower Manhattan
Weinstein who is 66 quote stepped back
from a black SUV
wearing a blazer and carrying books
under his arm and lumbered into a
Manhattan police station before a crowd
of news cameras he didn't respond to
shouts of Harvey according to the
Associated Press
after several accusations ranging from
inappropriate touching to rape emerged
against Weinstein last year dozens of
women came out to join the barrage the
chorus grew by the day more than 75
women who've now accused the former
movie producer
but Weinstein escaped criminal charges
until now on what charges he will face
the AP said quote the exact charges
against Weinstein still had not been
made public early on Friday - law
enforcement officials told the AP the
case would include allegations by Lucia
Evans an aspiring actress who has said
the Hollywood mogul forced her to
perform oral sex on him in his office
she was among the first women to speak
out about the producer one official said
it's likely the case will also include
at least one other victim who has not
come forward publicly as of yet so the
crime could carry up to 25 years in
prison so presumably Weinstein would die
in prison in the interview at The New
Yorker last October Evans said that
Weinstein forced her into the sex act
during a meeting at his office in 2004
she was then a rising senior at
Middlebury College she said over and
over I don't want to do this stop don't
I tried to get him away but maybe I
didn't try hard enough I didn't want to
kick him or fight him
actress Rose McGowan of course has come
out and said the Weinstein raped her in
1997 in Utah
Sopranos actress anabella's Chiara said
he raped her in a New York City
apartment in 1992 Norwegian actress and
Natasha Amalfi said he attacked her in a
London hotel room in 2008 according to
the Associated Press and of course at
the Cannes Film Festival an actress
named Asia Argento delivered an intense
speech before presenting the Best
Actress Award telling a horrific story
about Hollywood movie mogul Harvey
Weinstein quote I was raped by Harvey
Weinstein here at con I was 21 years old
this festival was his hunting ground so
obviously this is a big blow to sort of
Hollywood prestige as it has been for
mantra member the entire meeti movement
was launched on the back of the Harvey
Weinstein scandal Weinstein for his part
his lawyer said in court that Harvey
Weinstein did not create the casting
couch Harvey Weinstein was not the
creator of the casting couch the casting
couch that I've discussed before on the
show is this old Hollywood trope that
men who are in charge of Hollywood would
cast you in a film if you slept with
them right the casting couch was kept in
the office and then if you wanted to be
cast in a film you want to make your way
in Hollywood then you were forced to
sleep with the producer and they made
light of it movies going all the way
back to All About Eve right and All
About Eve which won Oscar for Best
Picture Marilyn Monroe plays this young
up-and-coming kind of floozy who wants
to get
the Broadway stage and so she is is
trying to woo fat ugly old producer
who's kind of portrayed in the in the
movie as this kindly old gentlemen right
this kind-hearted old gentleman he's
kind of a goofball generally the
Hollywood casting couch has been a part
of Hollywood for as long as Power has
been a part of Hollywood and the truth
is that this sort of behavior by men
toward women has been around as long as
men have wielded power in order to gain
sex for themselves it's also been
largely turned Hollywood for years
without any sort of repercussions
because many women were willing to use
the casting couch in order to get ahead
there are a lot of women who might not
have wanted to do that in the best of
all possible worlds but they were
willing to do it so you get into some
dicey areas of consent when you have
particular people who are okay with
sleeping with a reference on like their
first choice is not that first option
it's not something that they would love
to do in a scenario where they had the
option not to do it but they weren't
exactly forcibly raped right so when
we're not talking about Harvey Weinstein
who apparently forcibly right people but
there are a lot of situations in
Hollywood in which young women know that
the best way to get ahead is to use
their sexuality to get ahead and then
you run into some dicey areas with
regard to consent because if you say to
women you shouldn't be doing this right
there's a problem you should try to be
avoiding this then those women might say
well you're violating my grounds of
consent you're saying that I can't be a
fully autonomous individual capable of
making my own decisions and then what
you end up with is weird situations in
some cases I assume where you could have
the possibility that a woman goes to an
office the producer hits on her she
sleeps with the producer and then ten
years later when it comes out that the
producer is actually a rapist in this
case Harvey Weinstein then women come
forward they say well I was pressured
into sex - which is true informally if
not formally this is the problem with an
entire culture that prizes promiscuity
as a high value now again that's no
excuse for actual rape it's not a it's
not ending any excuse for actual use of
force
Harvey Weinstein should go to jail for
the rest of his life if any of these
allegations are true he should go to
jail for the rest of his life for the
rest of his life but it is also true
that Hollywood has forwarded this kind
of conduct for a very very long time and
it is widespread in Hollywood just the
latest case in point a bunch of women
are now accusing Morgan Freeman of
inappropriate behavior and harassment
according to CNN yesterday quote a young
production assistant thought she and
landed the job of her dreams when in the
summer of 2015 she started working on
going in style a bank heist comedy
starring Morgan frame
michael caine and alan arkin but the job
quickly devolved into several months of
harassment she told CNN she alleged that
Friedman subjected her to unwanted
touching and comments about her figure
and clothing on a near daily basis
Freeman rest his hand on her lower back
will rub her lower back she said in one
incident she said Freeman kept trying to
lift up my skirt and asking if I was
wearing underwear
he never successfully lifted her skirt
she said he would touch it and try to
lift it she would move away and then
he'd try again eventually she said Ellen
Ark and made comment telling him to stop
Morgan got freaked out and didn't know
what to say well this raises the
question it's why no one else on staff
was willing to tell Morgan Freeman to
stop and the answer is because if you
tell powerful Hollywood men to stop is
the other side of the coin you tell
powerful Hollywood men to stop you will
never get a job again and this is
exactly what happened with Harvey
Weinstein if anyone complained about
Harvey Weinstein he made sure that
nobody in town worked yet in Quentin
Tarantino admitted as much he said that
Harvey would call around and say this
person is a bad person to work with you
don't want to work with this girl
because she's trouble and then these
people wouldn't get jobs ever again so
when you have powerful men in positions
of high power this is why you need more
virtuous men in the industry this is why
you need more virtuous standards in the
industry you need a bunch of people
there who are not engaged in the sexual
revolution ethos of consent is the only
value because consent is sort of
fungible in a lot of these cases in some
cases it is not and in some cases like
it sounds like with Morgan Freeman it is
not but there are some cases in which
they're a bunch of men who have had
women saying yes to them for their
entire career because women want to get
ahead in some of these cases and then
these men decide okay well that means
all women want it because they're
scumbags
hey this sort of activity is going to be
more common in any society in which
there is a certain amount of credibility
given to men with power to do whatever
they want and there is a certain amount
of reluctance to call out women for
acting in fashions that forward this
particular standard so you need two
things in order to stop okay let's come
at this from the from the other end you
need two things in order to stop what's
happening in Hollywood what you need is
number one a bunch of women who are
willing to say no to directors and then
report on them and number two you need a
society willing to hear that and a bunch
of men in Hollywood who are willing to
stand with those women and I think I
should reverse the order of those what
you really first need is a bunch of men
who are willing to report other men for
doing these terrible things and those
men need to stand up and they need to
say no to people like Harvey Weinstein a
Morgan framing anymore alan arkin
situations you need fewer Jason
Bateman's the reason I mentioned Jase
Bateman is because you now have a
situation with Jason Bateman where he
did an interview with the New York Times
and a bunch of these men it was the
Arrested Development cast in in this
lengthy Q&A in the new york times of the
cast of Arrested Development Jeffrey
Tambor is still included on the show of
course one of the stars of the show he
was recently fired from transparant
after sexual harassment allegations and
the conversation eventually turned to
Tambor's behavior on the side of
arrested development according to
Jezebel reportedly there was an incident
onset in which Tambor yelled at his
co-star Jessica Walter who is who plays
Lucille Bluth and all of the men on the
show seems disturbingly interested in
brushing it off according to Jezebel so
Tambor apparently said that he expects
to be part of the next season and
Bateman said I wouldn't do it without
you I can tell you that and then Jessica
Walter interjected that that that Tambor
had had ripped on her had yelled at her
had lashed out at her and Bateman
immediately jumped in to defend Tamra
said we've all done this by the way
Walter said you've never yelled at me
and Bateman said not to belittle what
happened well she never yelled at me
like that
and then Bateman jumped in he said this
is a family and families you know have
love laughter arguments again not to
belittle it but a lot of stuff happens
in 15 years I know nothing about trans
parent but I do know a lot about
Arrested Development and I can say that
no matter what anybody in this room has
ever done we've all done a lot with each
other for each other against each other
I wouldn't trade it for the world and I
have zero complaints well nobody asked
you there talking to Jessica Walter and
then David cross again all of these
people are on the Left all of these
people are big believers in the feminist
movement and the meets you movement okay
so you have to ask yourself why is it
that all these believers in the media
movement in the feminist movement are so
willing to overlook the misconduct of
people with whom they work and the
answer is because in Hollywood this is
the way Hollywood works it is the way
Hollywood has always worked when Harvey
Weinstein goes out there and says I
didn't invent the casting couch yes he's
disgusting yes the casting couch is
disgusting yes moral people like me have
been saying for a long time people who
are religious have been saying for a
very long time the casting couch is
disgusting and the morality of Hollywood
is disgusting but Harvey Weinstein when
he says the casting couch was not
invented by Harvey Weinstein he's not
entirely wrong in that sense he's wrong
that he's not a rapist I mean it sounds
like she probably is a rapist but again
this puts you in a weird position
because all of these men who are
supposedly in favor of feminism are
standing around defending guys who are
acting like under grease balls so here's
David Cross he says you know one thing
Jeffery has said a lot of times that I
think is important
I often hear from somebody in his
position is that he has learned from the
experience and he's listening and
learning and growing that's important to
remember
well it's or more important to remember
that you shouldn't have acted like that
in the first place and then then the New
York Times reporter asked if somebody
approached you and said okay here's an
actor that admits he routinely yells at
directors and assistant directors at
co-workers assistants would you hire
that person and tambour said I would
hire that person if that person said you
know I've reckoned with this and then
Bateman said again not to belittle it or
excuse it or anything but in the
entertainment industry is incredibly
common to have people who are in quotes
difficult and when you're in a
privileged position to hire people or
have an influence and who does get hired
you make phone calls and you say hey so
I've heard about I've heard X about a
person who I tell me about that and what
you learn is context and you learn about
character and you learn about work
habits Wharf X Worth work ethics and you
start to understand because it's a very
amorphous process this sort of bleeping
that you do you know making up fake life
it's a weird thing and it's a breeding
ground for atypical behavior and certain
people have certain processes in other
words all of these people are difficult
people because they're artistes and
artistes have to be given more leeway to
do what it is they do accept those
people have victims and then a bunch of
women who don't want to get involved in
the casting couch system are forced into
the casting Cal system specifically
because they will lose jobs if they do
not it's it's a real disaster area all
the way through have a little more to
say on this first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at us ECA so
this is it this is the end I've been
talking about this for weeks but this is
your absolute last chance to get your
free gun you are a law-abiding Second
Amendment loving citizen you want to
defend your family you want to offend
your friends you want defend your
country well that's why the u.s. ECA is
giving five of five of you $1,000 to buy
an expensive new dream Kimber with laser
grips and extra ammo that's right five
of you will take home $1,000 and it is
completely free to enter but your
chances to win enter this to end this
Friday there will be no guns next week
simply go to defend my family now calm
and lock in your five free chances to
win right now it is that simple you can
enter in seconds it's 100% free you're
almost out of time before the US ECA
draws those five winners so get your
name on the winners list right now head
over to defend my family now calm to
enter before it's too late don't miss
these free guns it's your absolute last
chance to fend my family now calm to
lock in your five chances again the US
you see is wonderful wonderful group of
folks they help you out with legal
advice and education about guns and in
this case they're helping you have a
chance to actually win a Kimber so go to
defend my family now
let's defend my family now calm lock in
your five chances to win a thousand
bucks for your dream Kimber and again
get armed up as a as a law-abiding
Second Amendment loving citizen you SEC
a makes it easy for you defend my family
now
dot-com so you've got Harvey Weinstein
you've got Morgan Freeman you've got a
bunch of people defending people like
this you know it's it's really
troublesome and it's troublesome again
because so many folks in Hollywood
proclaim that they are the moral
standards that we must follow these are
the moral standards who they are the
they are the light bringers when it
comes to morality and decency and when
it comes to feminism - they're the light
bringers ok well they're gonna have to
learn how to balance two things one is
the ability of women to consent to
relationships with more powerful men and
the second is to call out men who are
doing terrible things and they haven't
learned how to balance these two things
yet they haven't learn how to balance
these two things because these two
things are sort of hard to balance and
in an era where is it power
relationships that are supposed to
define what's wrong or is a consent
that's supposed to define what's wrong
this has not been made clear by anybody
on the left yet now I'm of the opinion
that all relationships should number one
be consensual and number two power
should not be abused in this way by
powerful people and women should not
give in if they can help it
- abuse of power in this way if physical
force is not being used like be willing
to lose the job in order not to be
abused by man but I understand it's a
difficult decision that women should not
have to make and that's why we need to
change the system from within well
that's going to require two things it's
gonna require again powerful people
coming out and speaking out against this
n it's going to require an embrace of a
different sexual ethos that does not
value the art and the artists and
promiscuity above everything else it's
going to require a reversion back to
more traditional morality regarding how
people interact men and women interact
and I understand this makes a lot of
people I'm left uncomfortable but it's
very difficult to have it both ways you
can't say that men and women are just
playing around and then also be
surprised when it turns out that men are
willing to abuse that system in order to
do terrible things that doesn't mean the
men shouldn't be punished they should be
punished but the snapback is what some
people in Hollywood are finding so odd
to deal with and again I think that
there is I think there's a way to fix
all of this but I don't think it can be
fixed in the absence of a route change
in mentality about how men ought to
treat women how women ought to treat men
fortunately there is good news the good
news is Hollywood has its priorities
straight
when it comes to president Trump Sir
Robert De Niro who's a frequent critic
of President Trump and he's been playing
Special Counsel Robert Muller on
Saturday Night Live
he talked Tuesday about he'd like to bar
the president from eating at his Nobu
restaurant chain which I'm sure Trump
will just be devastated to learn the
Daily Mail reported that DeNiro a
co-founder of the Nobu restaurant and
hotel chain insisted he would not let
Trump eat in his restaurants and that he
would leave any other eatery where the
president entered if he walked into a
restaurant I was in I'd walk out said
DeNiro while chef Nobu Matsuhisa who's
De Niro's corner then joked it was his
dream for Trump to sit next to Janeiro
so he could make them sushi DeNiro of
course has spent a lot of time ripping
on Trump this is the way it works in
Hollywood the sort of virtue signaling
the matters is not the virtue signaling
where you stand up and you call out
actual predators in Hollywood that's not
virtually signaling real virtue
signaling real virtue signaling of
course is going and talking about how
Trump should not come into your
restaurant and by the way it's not
because Trump has this record with women
okay again
people in Hollywood probably don't care
about Trump's record with women they
care a lot more about President Trump's
politics they'd say the same thing about
George W Bush when Mitt Romney was
running in 2012 they would have said the
same thing about Mitt Romney because
these are the actual values in Hollywood
Hollywood likes to pretend that it has
values with regard to treatment of women
it doesn't ok Hollywood has no regard
for the values of women it has no regard
for the the the sexual autonomy of women
it has no regard for power relationships
between men and women but it certainly
wants to make sure that a Republican
doesn't enter its restaurants there are
certain things in Hollywood that'll
ensure that you never work again being
against same-sex marriage is one of them
being pro-life is a pretty good
indicator you're gonna have a tough time
working but sexually harassing the help
for years on end you can do that so long
as you are a powerful dude and most
people will go along with it and that's
why as soon as you see a gap in the in
the particular dam that's holding back
all these revelations in cases like
Harvey Weinstein or Morgan Freeman you
watch there will now be 15 women who
come forward and say all this stuff
because they've been held back by this
entire wall of silence that's been
created around Hollywood by Hollywood
about this sort of evil behavior by
people like Harvey Weinstein and people
like Morgan Freeman
all these women are gonna come forward
now because now they feel it's safe
there's safety in numbers to come
forward but you don't wanna be the first
one because if you're the first one you
end up like Rose McGowan and you lose
your job and you never work again
Hollywood's fault really truly egregious
and disgusting stuff okay well meanwhile
Joe Biden former vice president of the
United States he is out there
politicking he obviously wants to run
for president again he wants to run for
president he ran in 2008 didn't go
anywhere he wants to run for president
again in 2020 against President Trump
and he has a serious shot of winning the
nomination because presumably President
Obama would endorse him as his former VP
well Joe Biden is doing this routine
where he is suggesting the president
Trump has abandoned GOP values I find
this utterly hypocritical and hysterical
this is not your father's Republican
Party this is a different deal who we
are they're not who America is but what
they are doing is they're sending a
vision of America that's damaging that
is hurting us with this phony populism
okay so a nationalism I love the Joe
Biden's out there it's a different
Republican Party the Republican Party
has changed that route here's what the
studies show the studies showed that the
Republican Party has been in since 2010
absolutely stagnant in terms of its
politics it has not move to the right it
has not moved to the left his policies
are exactly the same as they were after
the Tea Party those have not changed the
only party that has moved is the
Democratic Party which has shifted
radically to the left when Joe Biden ran
in 2008 every Democratic candidate on
stage endorsed traditional marriage okay
when he ran in 2008 nobody on stage
would been paying homage to Bernie
Sanders they all thought he was a kook
in a nut job and now the entire
Democratic Party has moved radically to
the left and when you hear Joe Biden
talk about how much the Republican Party
has changed and moved remember Joe Biden
is the guy who said in 2012 just six
years ago he was saying the Mitt Romney
wanted to put y'all back in Chains
so Mitt Romney was the great outlier was
Mitt Romney who changed the Republican
Party Mitt Romney's Mathers moderate a
candidate as Republicans have run in the
last 25 to 30 years and yet there was
Joe Biden dripping on the Republican
Pyrus when you hear Democrats rip on the
extremism of Republicans understand that
they've been ripping on the supposed to
extremism of Republicans no matter how
moderate at any point the hypocrisy of
Joe Biden is truly astonishing here but
guess we shouldn't be astonished by Joe
Biden the guy wants to run for president
he understands he has to run to the hard
left if he wants to cut off people like
Pamela Harris and Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders okay so I want to give
you the update on the house in just a
second on the house race speak the house
did the race for control of the house in
just a second first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Skillshare so
Skillshare is the best way for you to
upgrade your resume here at the office
we've been using Skillshare for
everything whenever people need to learn
to use a new program whenever people
need to learn a new skill set whenever
we need to upgrade be cut in the
capabilities of our staff that's what we
use Skillshare for it's an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more you can take classes in social
media marketing or illustration or data
science or mobile photography creative
writing you name it they have it it's
these 45 minute classes taught by expert
I've taken a couple of their classes
than myself and they are really not only
out of fine but the experts are really
experts that really know what you're
doing you're not just pulling up a
YouTube video and finding some schlub
who may or may not know how to put a
nail to a hammer you're talking about
people who really know what they're
doing they are experts so whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set start a side hustle or just explore
that new passion skill share is there to
keep you learning and thriving
check it out join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for my
listeners right now you get two months
of skill share for just 99 cents that's
right skill share is offering the Ben
Shapiro show listeners two months of an
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to skill
shared comm slash Shapiro that skill
shared comm slash Shapiro go to skill
share calm slash capiro and you get
unlimited access for two months to 12 or
20,000 classes for just 99 cents once
you start you're not gonna want to stop
learning if you're one of my listeners I
know that you love learning I know you
love information I know you love making
yourself better
that's what Skillshare comm is for
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro let them
know that we sent you okay
so here's an update on the battle for
the house so with the Democrats still
struggling for an actual message the the
battle for the house has turned not in
their favor Shawn trend who's an
excellent analyst over at Real Clear
Politics he says this if you had asked
me six months ago who I thought would
win control of the House of
Representatives in 2018 I wouldn't have
hesitated before answering quote it's
early but Democrats are heavily favored
although conventional wisdom has been
very slow to catch up with a raft of GOP
retirements and highly vulnerable open
seats a president with job approval
ratings in the
and a generic ballot lead for democrats
in the double digits it was increasingly
difficult to spell out a path to victory
for republicans in fact things were bad
enough that it appeared their losses
could grow into the 40 or even 50 seat
range things have changed
says Sean Trend if the election were
held today it is not clear who would
hold the chamber I might put a thumb on
the scale for Republicans but right now
and it is still early the house is
likely to be closed like really close
once again conventional wisdom seems
slow to catch up where the animal is
still discussing the toxic environments
for Republicans okay president Trump's
job approval rating has been rising
there a bunch of reasons for people are
tired of the Muller investigation the
passage of the tax cut the good economic
news the generic ballot is moving look
at the polls it is narrowing
dramatically yeah in mid-december the
Democratic leaders around 13 points
today it is it three points that is a
massive movement and special elections
are not a good metric this is the most
important thing you've been hearing a
lot about Democratic turnout in special
elections and Sean Trans has hold up a
second he says some point to Democrats
performance in special elections as a
sign that their voters are energized
this is undoubtedly true I pointed to a
similar phenomenon in late 2013 so I do
think special election outcomes are
interesting but there are three problems
here I did not make specific projections
from these in 2013 because we don't have
a lot of experience projecting a midterm
election from special election results
these are informative data points but
until we have more experience seeing how
models based upon them perform we should
prefer establish metrics like job
approval and the generic ballot second
special elections all involve open seats
the one set of elections that didn't
involve open seats exclusively in
Virginia and New Jersey brought about a
set of results that are a lot less
encouraging for Democrats they lost in
Trump districts and they won in Hillary
districts well if that's replicated in
2018 Democrats would fall just shy of
winning the house so bottom line is the
prospects are looking much better for
Republicans than they were even a few
weeks ago and a lot of that is the
extremism of Democrats well I got Joe
Biden out there claiming that Donald
Trump has moved the Republican Party in
radical new ways my god look at these
Republicans with their populism here's
the reality the Democrats are radical
hey the latest point being obviously the
ms-13 argument right where President
Trump called ms-13 a bunch of animals
and then he doubled down on it and Nancy
Pelosi said that this was terrible
she said we believe some of those who
are attracted to the political arena
it's a government in public service that
we are all God's children there's a
spark
of divinity among every person on earth
and she's defending ms-13 now as I said
earlier this week President Trump has a
magic power his magic powers he can make
Democrats defend legitimately anything
so one of the polls say about the ms-13
issue well according to the hill 56
percent of American adults in the
Harvard Cape's
Harris Poll said referring to members of
the gang as animals is fair compared to
44 percent who said the characterization
was unfair a slimmer majority 52 percent
added that the comments that dehumanized
members of ms-13 are acceptable so in
other words Trump's on the right side of
the American public on this particular
issue by the way he is also on the right
side of the American public with regard
to the kneeling situation the kneeling
in the NFL situation as I mentioned
yesterday I'm not a fan of the
president's interjecting himself into
arguments about what a private
corporation the NFL should do about its
own employees exercising their right to
kneel okay like it's a private company
they can do what they want I think the
president Trump polarizing the issue is
not good for the country but as I
mentioned yesterday it is good for him
there's no question that he's on the
right side of the polls on this
particular issue most Americans do not
have tons of sympathy for people who are
kneeling for the National Anthem
they just don't and this is why when
Democrats people I'm left come out and
labeled Trump an idiot for him ripping
on people who are kneeling for the
national anthem they're only hurting
themselves Doug Baldwin is a wide
receiver for the Seattle Seahawks and he
calls Trump an idiot over all of the
kneeling controversy well this is the
kind of stuff Trump eats up and spits
out it is great for Trump
[Music]
listen you know I respect the man
because it's a human being you know
first and foremost but he's just being
more divisive which is not surprising
most Americans look at the situation in
the NFL they don't think Trump was the
one who was originally divisive on this
most Americans think that it was the NFL
players who decided to kneel from the
national anthem a signal of unity in the
United States who are actually being
divisive in this entire process so the
more people react to Trump by taking the
side of the people who are kneeling
that's exactly what Trump wants this is
what's so funny if the left even half
understood what was going on in this
particular debate maybe they might make
a more shaded argument maybe they would
argue as actually people like me have
argued that Trump should not involve
himself in these particular issues
because it polarizes the country but
they are in favor of people standing for
the national anthem the NFL has a right
to do what it wants to do the hilarious
thing about all of this is the NFL is
getting just shellacked
over this decision right Fox Sports 1
has a show with with Skip Bayless and
Skip Bayless and his co-host I can't
remember who it is they were talking
about this this NFL controverts they
called it a dark day in American sports
Bell is highly respected very he's not a
shock jock he's not go over the top with
his criticism he's very even-handed he
is a black man but that's a strong
powerful conclusion from Jarrett Bell
about what just happened and it does
feel to me from this side of the desk
like it was a dark day in American
sports okay it's so hilarious that this
is the this quote dark day in American
sports this co-host is Shannon Sharpe
they're the this is such a dark day in
American sports the NBA has had this
exact same policy this exact same policy
for a long time okay the NBA's had this
policy since like 1994 1995 and yet
nobody's complaining about that they
only complain when the NFL changes the
policy because it looks like a quote
unquote win for Trump and by the way the
implication that Trump is a racist and
that's the reason he cares about all of
this
yesterday Donald Trump pardoned the late
black boxing champion Jack Johnson hey
Jack Johnson was issued a posthumous
pardon he was the first African American
heavyweight champion who's jailed a
century ago due to his relationship with
a white woman okay he was accused of
violating federal law by transporting
his white wife
a woman who later became his wife named
Lucile Cameron in 1912 across state
lines is supposedly violated the Mann
Act and sexual trafficking of course
that wasn't true was trumped up but Jack
Johnson was was convicted he was
convicted nonetheless he died in 1946
okay the president signed the pardon and
yet we're still hearing from people that
obviously all of his stances here are
due to racism it just doesn't wash in
terms of public relations okay so I have
a little bit more to say about sports
and where America stands in just second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at Tommy John so Tommy
John makes the best underwear that you
will ever wear okay you don't think a
lot about your underwear but the truth
is that after you've worn your underwear
this cheap pair of underwear that you
got after you've worn it five or six
times it's gone through the wash it's
starting to fall apart it's starting to
sag it's starting to roll on you okay
Tommy John doesn't do any of those
things more than half a million dudes
have switched to Tommy John these
proprietary fabrics innovative designs
to make sure the legs never ride up the
waistband never rolls down it is
impossible to get a wedgie
yeah beum would've been amazing for me
as a teenager if it'd been impossible to
get a wedgie with underwear unbelievable
Plus Tommy John has a time-saving
horizontal quick-draw fly that can only
be described as incredible if you don't
believe me you can try it for yourself
because Tommy John is backed by a best
pair you'll ever wear or it's free
guarantee so you have nothing to lose
join the revolution against
uncomfortable undergarments make the
switch to Tommy John there is no
adjustment needed Tommy John hey go to
Tommy John comm slash up here you get
20% off your first order
pretty solid deal Tommy John comm slash
capiro 20% off your first order these
things are well made I mean they've gone
through the wash for me many a time and
they always come out as good as new
they're really great Tommy John comm
slash up here Oh 20% off again use that
slash Shapiro to let them know that we
sent you these underwear are just
terrific okay so before I go any further
on the sports front first I want to say
that you have to go over and subscribe
you have to okay we're gonna do the
mailbag in just a little while here if
you subscribe you get to be part of the
mailbag so congratulations to you ask me
all of your deepest darkest questions
and we'll answer them publicly and
hopefully not humiliate you too badly
you get all of that when you subscribe
so go over for $9.99 a month it's daily
wire you can subscribe $99 a year gets
the annual subscription the
subscriptions also come with some other
great features such as we are doing
events in Dallas and Phoenix if you had
been a subscriber you would have been
able to buy first seats at these events
we've been able to get a VIP ticket at
these events as subscriber before and
one else and that means we could have
met but now we can't meet because you're
not a subscriber so if you want to meet
then you should subscribe I mean this is
what I'm saying to you folks I don't
know what to tell you if you want to
help out me on the show obviously also
get a lot of letters how can I help
subscribe it really does help us check
it out
also I'd like to point out that on
Sunday we are bringing you our Sunday
special our Sunday special this week
features dr. drew which is pretty cool
so dr. drew stopped by and the
conversation I will say is definitely
free willing here's dr. drew talking
about how awesome it is hey I'm dr. drew
I'm very excited to be a part of the
bench peer shows Sunday special and we
Ben and I are gonna talk about
everything I am I want him to change my
mind I want to grow and build and maybe
a little philosophy maybe a little
psychology listen you won't want to miss
it okay it's really a lot of fun so
check it out on Sunday if you haven't
subscribe you should just it's on our
regular feed so if you're already
subscribing you'll get it automatically
in your feed if not go subscribe right
now on this podcast and you'll get my
conversation with dr. drew for the full
hour as Larry King would say please
subscribe please leave us a review just
want to listen for free we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so final note on this this whole
NFL controversy I think the whole thing
is overblown I think it's overblown
because two things can be true at once
one we do not want to pressure our
corporations to crack down on people for
their speech second if it is actively
impeding a corporation's ability to
distribute the product okay if the free
speech amounts to you providing a design
flaw in the product itself then the
corporation it seems to me has every
right to do something about you okay so
as I say me speaking at a private
college and being barred from a private
college they can do it but I think it's
stupid
you boycotting the NCAA over an
unrelated bathroom policy in the state I
think is stupid you boycotting Brendon H
from Mozilla Firefox because Brendon ice
was Pro traditional marriage and has no
effect on the product that's stupid but
the product the NFL puts on the field
includes all of the visual product
before the game including the national
anthem so if the NFL says listen we're
losing money because of this because the
product we are putting on we believe to
be inferior at least in terms of how it
is grabbing audiences well they have
every right to do what they're going to
do and I think that's how you balance
these two things okay there are certain
things that are inherent to the
development to the product there are
certain things that are not again if
they wanted to kneel for the national
anthem every day before they started
their factory work I don't see how that
would really be a problem but all of
this is televised and has an impact on
whether people watch the games or not so
people who are failing to make this
distinction they're friends of mine who
I think are failing to make this
distinction
I rarely disagree with my good friend
David French David had a piece in the
New York Times in which he argued that
the NFL should not have changed policy
they should have allowed everybody to
continue kneeling I'm not quite as sold
on that and I don't equate every
situation in which a private corporation
is trying to save its product from with
every other situation in college campus
is a place obviously for exchange of
ideas NFL pregame doesn't seem to me
like that's what it was generally for as
a rule okay so let's go through some
mailbag let's do some mailbag so Aslan
says hey Ben I'm a subscriber and watch
you all the time well Thank You Asselin
I know how to combat the general
ridiculous nature the left and their
meltdown over current events I'm a bit
confused about one of my friends who
worked for the bush administration and
since President Trump has been elected
he's gone full sjw and left ideals he
argues that his era of the Republican
Party is dead because of Trump and
everything from does against his view of
what the Republican Party was in
president's past my question is the
Republican Party so very different under
Trump than some of his great
publicans of old or is he just being
ridiculous most of trumps policies are
great I think as far as conservative
values but he's just a buffoon at times
in a way no president has been before
thanks huge fan ok so this is the
serious question right we talked a
little bit earlier about Joe Biden and
Joe Biden saying the Republican Party
has massively shifted what was stupid
about what Joe Biden said is he was
saying that there was this populist move
in the Republican Party the policy is
exactly the same as it has been for
years and President Trump has governed
more conservatively than george w bush
president Trump's first year-and-a-half
of policy is a conservative dream in
many ways really like as a conservative
but somebody who's very very skeptical
of President Trump's policies I can say
I've been very pleased by his policy
decisions that said is Trump a
difference in kind for the Republican
Party yes I mean he is I mean there's no
question that he's a man of different
character than Republicans have elected
before in some ways that's a good thing
right in some ways it means that he
violates certain taboos that need to be
violated and that was certainly true
when he moved the US Embassy to
Jerusalem for example it's also true
when he attacks actual fake news but
they're obviously downsides to this
president Trump lacks character when it
comes to women I think this is obviously
clear president Trump has made
statements that I find absolutely
morally egregious have called them out
on this show many times you know that is
a sea change for Republicans
particularly if they go along with that
sort of thing
publicly which is why I've always said
that if Republicans want to maintain
their moral Center they should clap for
President Trump when he does good things
and he's doing a lot of those things and
they should boo President Trump when he
does something bad because President
Trump can take it and he's a human and
that means that all humans should be
treated equally not as idols not as as
objects of pandering but President Trump
when he says something truly bad
everybody should say hey that's truly
bad you shouldn't say that and when he
does something's really bad they should
say hey that's truly bad you shouldn't
do that no he does something good you
have to praise him I think if you take
this tack with your friend then maybe
you'll be a little bit more open to your
messaging about the fact that Trump
really hasn't changed a lot of policy on
the Republican side of the aisle because
he hasn't Jonathan says hey Ben should
the government force force food
producers to put nutritional information
on their products Thanks
no I don't think they should I don't
think that the government has any
business telling food producers what
information to put on their products in
fact I'm not I'm a libertarian this I
don't even think I'm not a big fan of
the FDA I think that the food and drug
administration the idea that you needed
a government agency to ensure the safety
of your food I think that's largely
stupidity I think there are private
companies the
could do just the same thing now we have
Saget's that rates restaurants I don't
see any reason you can have a private
organization that essentially licenses
food not licenses in the sense they
could ban a food but looks at a food and
says whether it is healthy or not
whether it is whether it is good or not
right there are private organizations
that I think could do this fairly well
and you know if one was dishonest and
there would be others that competed with
it I think it's something the market
certainly has room for I don't think
there's a market failure taking place in
food in other words right you don't
actually have to have an FDA telling you
the ingredients in your light bulbs
although presumably they do there are
government regulations that force that
sort of thing I don't think that's
necessary because I don't think that
most producers have an interest in
killing their consumers or making food
so bad for them that they never want to
eat that food again and competition
allows you to do this first of all I
think that the nutritional product
information would end up on the bottles
anyway because I think that some
creative producer would say you know
what we should undercut our competition
by saying we are completely transparent
about what's in our food as opposed to
our competition which presumably would
then drive the competition to actually
put the nutritional products out there
into mean you see this all the time
right you see this in terms of diet
products so I'm not sure why it
shouldn't apply to food more generally
Richard said you've mentioned usually
when talking about one of your sponsors
about how you use an electric razor and
only part of your face for religious
reasons could you explain the doctrine
in more detail please sure I mean the
quick answer is that in the Bible it
says that you're not supposed to shave
the corners of your beard oh and
Orthodox Jews take that to mean that you
are not supposed to use a straightedge
to shave your face and so I use an
electric razor around my entire face and
then the draw line and then below the
draw line are there certain commentators
who say that you're allowed to use a
straightedge below there because you
know when you're shaving your neck
that's really not a part of your beard
okay Dylan says hey Ben what is your
opinion on wives not taking their
husband's last name when they get
married do you believe that is harmful
to their union or is this something that
shouldn't be of concern Thanks so my gut
reaction is that it is important for
wives to take their husband's last name
because you are now forming an
independent unit and you should have the
last name because now you are part of a
team if you join the New York Yankees
you don't maintain that you are a Yankee
Cardinal right if you sign as a free
agent and you become a Yankee and it
seems to me the same thing should be
true now there's a there are people who
say well why shouldn't you take your
wife's last name well listen if you want
to do that you can and I think that's
sort of emasculating to dudes because I
do think that there are male and female
roles in a relationship and a man who
feels that he doesn't have any sort of
leadership in
his relationship with his wife is going
to feel emasculated this is just the
natural human process not saying whether
it's right or wrong that is just natural
I'll tell you this one night when we got
married when I got married my wife I
said she didn't have a middle name and
her last name her her maiden name was
Toledano and my wife wanted to I said to
her that she could do like my mom and
she could actually take her maiden name
and make it her middle name like I
shouldn't even have permission she can
do whatever she wants right she's an
autonomous human being but I said if you
want to do that it's fine with me I
don't care and it came time for us to go
over to Social Security office for to
formally change her name to - you know
her name Shapiro - dr. Shapiro and she
and she went in and she said you know I
decided not to do it and the reason I
decided not to do it is because I want
to take your last name it's it's my gift
to you and I you know I'm not I'm still
member of my old family but this is our
family now our family is the Shapiro
family and it meant a lot to me it did
mean a lot to me as man I promise you
women if you ask men whether it means
something to them most men will say it
means something to them because it is a
sacrifice a woman is making of her
family name I and that should mean
something that's a sacrifice okay so yes
I think it's important and I think that
it's it's enough of an important thing
that you should ask your potential
spouse about it and I don't think that
if let's put this way I think that the
types of people do different things on
this issue if you are a hardcore
feminist and you think that it's a real
sacrifice to give up your last name for
your husband's last name because this
means he owns you now I would suggest
that you're not being generous enough to
the husband that you're marrying I don't
think the matter of ownership I think
it's a matter of let's be on the same
team okay if we that's just my general
take David says hey we often talk about
the left side ia's and practices is
self-destructive and I agree on those
points but do you have an expectation
that the left will ever actually destroy
itself and become genuinely relevant in
American culture and policy it seems
like they keep drinking poison but it's
only making them stronger they shoot
themselves in the foot and it never
really slows them down no I don't think
the left is ever going to go away I
think it will always be with us I think
that leftism Springs from a couple of
elements of human nature one is jealousy
and the other is utopianism and I think
as long as jealousy and utopianism are
parts of human nature there will be a
left to fight because jealousy is the
basis for economic policy you earn more
than I do there Fridays are of your
money and utopianism is the idea that if
we just shift government policy there
will be a huge number of new human
beings will be created and these new
human beings will be transcended human
beings better human beings more generous
human beings and then we will all have a
beautiful world where the unicorns
prance and play in the meadows with
raindrops smiles right it's just it's
stupid but unfortunately this is part of
human nature we think we can change
everything it's why whenever anything
bad happens anything bad in the United
States our first reaction is why didn't
the government do something about it and
we should really be asking ourselves why
didn't I do anything about it and if I
didn't do anything about it can anyone
do anything about it and is it possible
that the collective can't solve
everything and then maybe you say okay
well maybe the collective can solve this
one but we should at least ask ourselves
the question leftism is rooted in human
nature okay just as conservatism I think
is actually more of a I think
conservatism is actually more of a
departure from human nature right your
kid is a leftist your two-year-old is
leftist my two-year-olds leftist my
two-year-old wants stuff when he wants
it and he wants it right now he doesn't
care how he got it and then Cameron came
about he doesn't care that if he screams
now now now now now it's not just going
to appear and he thinks that if I give
things to him then life will magically
be transformed hey and you are a
communist in your relationship with your
own family right you have a joint bank
account you share with your family you
earn from each according to his ability
to each according to his need is
basically the rule inside my house
anyway but that does not mean that that
is a good idea for the governance of
society as a whole or that it instills
any sort of responsibility which is why
you have to fight a communists signature
of the family with the idea of teaching
responsibilities and inculcating
responsibility in your children brian
says hi ban O'Sullivan's law states that
any institution not actually on the
right will eventually end up on the left
the truth of this statement is
indisputable we see examples of this
every day
the news media educational institutions
at every level religious denominations
professional organizations civic
organizations like the Boy Scouts
corporations what causes of this is
there any way to counter it well in many
ways this answer is the same as my last
answer any organization that is not
overtly embracing particular
responsibilities of particular
principles about personal responsibility
and god-given rights eventually is going
to be eaten up by this quest for cosmic
justice that Thomas Sol talks about when
Thomas Oil has a great book called the
quest for cosmic justice I highly
recommend that everybody read it and it
basically explains the the desire of
human beings to look for answers in
places where they can't get answers and
organizations particularly our
collective in nature and that means that
they tend to think they can solve
everything through the collective so
it's not really surprised they move in a
collectivist direction michael says
hello benevolent and fearless leadership
here Wow
I like that what are you getting me his
Holiness Pope Saint Michael Knowles and
sweet and st. sweet little ELISA for
their upcoming wedding I absolutely love
the show and left his tears taste even
sweeter and daily wired tumblr thanks
well Michael I appreciate it and I
appreciate the Michael is the person who
wrote that write it says what are you
getting His Holiness Pope Saint Michael
moles and the person who wrote this is
Michael so Michael nice try but Michael
already knows when I got Michael because
we were sitting next to each other okay
so this is a good story so the other day
there was an event that we had to go to
I was a really terrific event with some
some big-name Hollywood folks at like a
launch it was really fun and I was and
our entire company won so there they're
a bunch of people from our company we're
supposed to go we were all supposed to
carpool over so I come out it's it's
like 12:00 noon I'm supposed to be there
at like 1225 and I have been told that
we are all going to carpool out together
so I'm in my studio at the Daily wire
offices and I saunter my way on out at
about 12:10 because I've been doing work
you know to make everyone money and then
I walk out of my office and I look
around and everyone is gone everyone is
gone and I look around and then I asked
my assistant the only person left in the
office you know where'd everybody go
and she said where was everybody
supposed to be somewhere I so I don't
know I mean you tell me
and I call my business partner and he
says you're supposed to be here right
now and right at that moment all of my
co-workers and employees walk in without
me because they left me there that's the
kind of office we have here at daily
wire so anyway we go to this lunch and I
sit down and unfortunately I would
seated directly next to the execrable
Michael moles and I mean listen I didn't
make the seating chart okay not on me
so I sit down and Michael moles is
sitting next to me and then it hits me
that Michael's wedding is coming up in
the next week and that I have not gotten
him anything for his wedding frankly I
hadn't really thought about because who
cares I mean it's Knowles's wedding like
really so anyway I'm sitting next to him
and it strikes me that you know if I
don't get him anything like right now I
will forget about it five minutes later
and then I just won't get him anything
and I wouldn't care would save me money
but I think he'd feel bad about it and
then we'd all have to feel bad and then
it would cause a little drama that she
Knowles is and in anyway he's sitting
next to me so I pull up his his wedding
registry I get him a blender and then I
turned him and say congratulations you
have a blender so that's basically what
I got my god I'm a blender okay there's
your answer
story for a short question okay
Christian says hey Ben what is your
stance on the argument that the
executive branch should practice
discretion on enforcing laws as it is
parts of the checks and balances well I
think the executive branch obviously has
the veto power but in terms of enforcing
laws that are already on the books by
Congress it is job to enforce laws not
to decide not to enforce the laws unless
those laws are expressly
unconstitutional now this is a serious
issue
okay the executive branch does have the
ability to say listen this law is
unconstitutional
I'm not going to enforce it
unfortunately we've now shifted our
vision of the government so that the
executive branch does not have the duty
to independently say that this is not
actually constitutional I'm not going to
enforce it instead they kick it over to
the judicial branch they kick it all the
way over to the judicial branch and they
say well I'll enforce it whether its
constitutional or not it's up to the
judiciary to decide that is false that
it's false okay the system was not built
for that the system was built so that
members of the executive branch take a
constitutional oath to uphold the
Constitution and that means Velocity's
unconstitutional even over their veto
they should at least be able to
challenge Congress on it and then if
Congress wants to impeach Congress can
impeach but everybody was supposed to
uphold their constitutional duty not
just the judicial branch Justin says hey
Ben hypothetical question if you were US
president had majority support in the
House and Senate what policy would you
push regarding taxation in the nation
mostly I'm interested in how you'd want
to collect taxes from citizens like
income tax tax brackets if at all how
much to tax etc well you know I've moved
sort of in favor of the idea of a fair
tax which is essentially a national
sales tax with with certain exceptions
for people who are more impoverished I
like that idea better than the income
tax I don't think it's the government's
business how much money I earn and I
think the income tax is rife with
corruption there's a reason that the
state of California has the highest
income taxes in the nation and also the
number-one rate of tax deductions in the
nation so we pass all these stupid high
taxes and we vote for all the
politicians to pass the stupid high
taxes and then we all take enormous
deductions in order to avoid the high
taxes we just voted for I don't like the
income tax I think that the fair tax is
probably the way that I would go okay a
couple of more here Matthew says hey Ben
I'm a practicing Christian for over a
decade have been a vocal conservative
for about the past four to five years
lately I've been having church members
come and telling me I need to stop
posting my political beliefs that I need
to choose between my faith and my
politics I need advice on how to handle
that I don't believe I should have to
choose between the two well I find that
a weird argument and frankly I think
faith should be the value system that
under
your politics and these should be able
to make a secular argument for whatever
politics you hold but I think that we
all have certain basic assumptions about
the nature of life as I say in my new
book and I think that those values are
allowed to come from a religious place
so that this is a weird argument to me I
don't really understand it Spencer says
if you were writing a contemporary comic
version of Dante's Inferno what eternal
punishments or rewards would you assign
to President Trump Bernie and Hillary
for instance would Bernie be condemned
to forever reach for pudding cups the
receipt out of his grasp and to what
gruesome tortures would you consign
Michel moles in the afterlife I shudder
to think of it so the gruesome torture
to which I would consign Michel moles is
that he would have to talk constantly
into a camera that was dead that would
be his gruesome torture and also he
would have to wear a shirt at all times
wouldn't matter he goes in the shower he
has to wear a shirt he's never allowed
to take off his shirt that's the rules
hey that those those are the rules okay
as far as Trump Bernie and Hillary I
think life has a beautiful way of giving
certain punishments to people who
deserve them Hillary's already got her
punishment she's not President of the
United States and she got humiliated by
Donald Trump so I think that eternal
that would probably be her punishment
right also she'd have to she'd have to
probably sit there and grin as people
made speech after speech about how great
her husband was I think that would be an
excellent eternal punishment for Hillary
Clinton for Bernie Sanders I think that
the eternal punishment is that he should
actually have to be he should have to
work for a living like he should
actually have to go work like get it get
a real job like a normal person and then
he should have to give charity like a
normal good person would that would be
his eternal punishment which sounds to
me pretty good but for him it would just
be terrible and president from sea
turtle punishment he'd eternally be
forced to stare at a Playboy centerfold
forever but he can't do anything about
it she just stands there forever and he
just stares at her and there's nothing
he can do it's just an eternal case of
of the wants but not the gets so it
would be I think that would be pretty
fair for President Trump and Molly says
hey Ben I'm participating in an
archeological excavation the summer in
Jerusalem I'm super excited but with all
that has been going on lately my
family's worried about my safety
since you're more familiar with
Jerusalem what would you say to help
ease their minds about my safety Thanks
well terrorism is extraordinarily
uncommon in Israel is it is the source
of very few injuries and deaths in
Israel Israel is actually really safe at
this point there are soldiers on every
corner and there are certain things that
you can avoid that the Israeli
government will tell you to avoid but
there's certain ways to make yourself
safer just to show your family
you'll take the safest possible measures
you know yeah I know this is
controversial inside Israel Pete a lot
of people take the bus if I were an
Israel I probably wouldn't take the bus
that's a very common site for terrorist
attacks to occur but that's because I'm
over cautious again Israel is an
extraordinarily safe place at this time
ok so we will be back here next week
with more mailbag let's do a quick thing
I like and then a quick thing that I
hate so yesterday I mentioned a show
called the white queen all about Richard
the third the last three episodes the
show about Richard the third and they
paint Richard the third in a very
positive light another book that sort of
paints Richard the third and a positive
light is book called the daughter of
time by Josephine tey one of the great
mysteries of all time the book is all
about basically a detective who's a
frequent a frequent character and
Josephine Hays novels and this detective
this time is laid up in bed and he
decides that he is going to unravel the
mystery of what actually happened to
Richard the Third's nephews I did
Richard the third actually kill his
nephews and the book is really gripping
and really interesting and really
historical so check it out one of the
great mystery novels of all time the
daughter of time by Josephine Tay makes
for a good weekend read for sure okay a
quick thing that I hate so when I say
Hollywood is out of touch I mean
Hollywood is really out of touch they
did a movie called show dogs they show
dogs is a movie about what you would
think show dog stars Will Arnett as an
FBI agent named Frank who is forced into
partnering with the talking dog named
Max voiced by Ludacris to infiltrate a
prestigious dog show in the hopes of
rescuing a kidnap panda yep sounds
awesome but that's not the best part so
the best part of this is that apparently
there is a plot point involving max
learning to cope with the idea of having
a judge examine his genitals while
competing in the dog show the problem is
this is a movie for children okay and
his daily waiter pointed out having a
judge fondle a dog and then the dog talk
about how good it feels is not really a
great message to be forwarding for small
children well now show dogs has actually
been pulled from the theaters even
leftist sources like Slate we're saying
this is not really particularly great
daily where I will say was I think
involved in pulling it a week after its
debut pulled an abysmal 6 million on its
opening weekend a rotten score of 23% on
the tomato meter well now the film's
producers have released a statement
apologizing to offended parent and
they're gonna fix the film they've
decided to remove those two scenes from
the movie which were not appropriate for
children that seems
appropriate to me since I don't think
the children should be taught that it
feels good to have your genitals
stimulated by an adult that's really
disgusting
so thanks Hollywood I can't imagine why
you're so screwed up in every possible
way okay well we will be back here next
week with much much more I'm Ben Shapiro
this is Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is produced by Senya Villarreal
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike her Amina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing